[Music]
elon musk is the richest person on earth
because of tesla and increasingly
because of his startup spacex tesla
stock took off like a rocket ship in the
early days of covid but has since
stalled by contrast spacex has chugged
along steadily but how does anyone who's
not a friend of elon invest in spacex
which is not even publicly traded
if you've got the money start your own
firm so that when spacex needs to raise
capital you can join a funding round but
you'll need the right silicon valley
contacts and even then you may have to
pay up five percent management fee to
team up with other investors carried
interest maybe even an access fee
[Music]
you can buy private shares from early
investors looking to cash out but you
have to be an accredited investor also
demand is high which means shares are
often unavailable and when they are the
deals close quickly
you can buy funds that own dozens of
hand-picked companies including spacex
but these are difficult to access or are
closed-end
other options buy google's parent
alphabet which invested almost a billion
dollars in spacex in 2015 but alphabet
is so big it's unlikely to move on
spacex's prospects or you can buy other
companies in the same industry